i hate that person i hate what they did
to me i'm gonna write a character about
them and i'm gonna show everybody
how do you write evil
easily enough unfortunately i think we
got a lot of evil in all of us so it's
okay to just dive into the part of us
that's dark
if
i'm uh
you know it's i think writing evil is
to write evil you have to almost pretend
like no one's going to read it because
you don't want you don't want anyone to
think you're evil oh my god i would
never be that evil well there's just a
beauty to knowing
we all have an evil
inside of us and we can go there we just
choose not to sure so
there's there's just a beauty of just
really letting it go on the page and not
um
and and some people read it and be like
oh you know i mean i you know i can't
write serial killers like that that
narrative just that scares me i don't
like
even i i can never watch a serial killer
film those things just don't make sense
to me but
you know we we can find
we we can embrace
the um
our tendencies because because we all
have bad in us
it's you know and we're not uh
we're not politicians well well
politicians are more bad than people
than normal but um
but we're not trying i don't think we
need to present ourselves
as beautiful flowers
we're all a little corrupt
um
and
especially
in the film industry you see a lot more
corruption but under the guise of like
oh this is virtue and you get behind the
curtain a little bit and you're like ooh
so
it's
it's kind of easy to write evil it's
it's it's almost easier to write evil
than it is to write a
you know evil's interesting it is
and do you think it's more interesting
to write a virtuous character
who secretly has evil
or
an evil character that you know you see
it and you go okay this is definitely
evil and then
you're seeing sort of what that person's
life is like are we more intrigued by
what's not shown and what we're
discovering as the audience
as well i'll first answer that as the
writer so what i try to do
is when i find i go back into my life
and i go you know what i hate that i
hate that person i hate what they did to
me i'm gonna write a character about
them and i'm gonna show everybody just
what a piece of crap human being this
person is and when this person watches
the movie they're gonna go oh my god
that's me i need to change my life so
that's the original intent and then i
start working on the character and i
start massaging the character and then i
start to realize oh crap i have empathy
for the character and then i develop
more and more empathy and i'm like oh
crap that character is part of me
um
the character may never really grow in
the story may still
be a piece of crap in the story
but
i develop empathy
for why
they're not good people um but as far as
the layers of an evil person having
virtue and a virtuous person having evil
i think it's about i i want to tackle
both of those both of those intrigue me
to no end because there is a flip side
to everything there's
so it's um
it's uh and and i don't think
i i would actually the virtuous person
who has
who's not getting in touch with the evil
would intrigue me more than working with
on an evil person that's uh has virtue
because because there's um
[Music]
there with uh with a virtuous person
they're they're actively pushing down
that evil where with with an evil person
they're actively going i'm virtuous no
really i'm virtuous
can you think of any characters that
bring to mind that are evil that you
actually have empathy for i know a lot
of people have talked about the joker
but that you go you know what maybe this
person there's there's you have some
soft spot for that person yeah and well
the evil characters i mean for the most
part the antagonist
um if it's a like like a superhero movie
or a james bond or a mission impossible
the the antagonist has to be more
interesting than the hero i think uh
that the layers got to be there
and then
then we're like how is the hero going to
get through this
um
so i find uh the
do i have empathy for the for the hero
for the antagonist
um and those kind of hero type movies um
i think i just get a kick out of how
evil they are and i'm like happy they're
evil because i'm sitting there enjoying
their evilness and how how is tom cruise
going to get through
blank blank blank um
you know in the in those in those total
formula movies that i just adore beyond
belief i know they're not going to die
at the end that's not the question the
question is how are they not going to
die that's what that's what keeps us
watching
why is evil important in storytelling i
think we're intrigued with eagle evil
uh i think
if we i mean you know i grew up in a
very religious household so there's the
bible the bible is just all evil this is
bad this is bad this is bad don't do
this
and there's there's a lot of and then
they go through this there's so many
evil stories in the old testament you're
like wait god's telling you to kill your
own son you know there's there's um
i think
our collective mythology has just a ton
of evil in it and um
we may try to paint it as like oh no no
we're all good we're all good but you
think about you know how we got here and
what's going on
and
evil is the theme uh you know genghis
khan
man you know that guy's a hero of his
narrative but what did he do
um actually i can't remember what did he
do
he pillaged he pillaged and you know
it's like the norwegians the vikings you
know what did they do you know they were
they're heroes of their own stories but
they're decimating cultures
so um
i i think uh i think it's a general
narrative of
what uh
what we should explore
um and that's
and then how and then how are we coping
with
the evil around us and then how are we
coping how are we coping with
empathizing with evil things you know
and there's times when
there's beautiful times when i have evil
thoughts even if i'm just driving around
los angeles and i'm like that person who
cut me off probably shouldn't exist on
this earth there's a little joy to
having that fantasy even though we don't
act out the fantasy but we do get to
write down the fantasy
so
i i think
i don't think um you know we don't go
through the whole day with all virtuous
thoughts i was i was just at starbucks
getting a cup of coffee and this idiot
in front of me is like
had this huge two different credit cards
you know all these all these
stipulations to his order all he got was
one drink and one thing i thought he was
an uber eats guy
and this guy is just
and i'm sitting there going that guy
might be
you know it's part of the human
collective he may be dispensable and
then it's just
you know it's it's a fun thought to
think about but in real life we never do
it and then if i followed him home i
would see that he's a good father to his
kids and he was just having a rough day
so that's you know there's
where there's um
evil and there's empathy we need we need
the whole we i guess we need the whole
story and that's why we tell the story
we need the whole story
to map out the the whys of uh he was the
antagonist in my life for five minutes
because my venti coffee was late
okay no i i talk about going way out no
i i saw someone at a store the other day
trying to return something but quote
didn't have the credit card and was
arguing and the workers were very nice
and they said i'm really sorry sir if
you come back with the credit card
you'll be fine no no i need service and
and wouldn't take no for an answer and
in that moment
i'm looking at the person like okay this
is weird and doesn't seem right
but who knows maybe legitimately it
didn't have the credit card and it just
he had the receipt
or they shouldn't be on this earth
anymore they had all this stuff but
my point is i mean we we see uh we used
to see tabloids and we would see evil
there and now we can go on social media
and now we're all judges of what's evil
um even if it's one video of somebody
pushing someone in a convenience store
yeah and we don't know what happened on
the other end to prom we don't know we
just see that one snippet you know and
so now we're watching evil played out in
in real life quote unquote but we don't
know who really was the offending party
who was the first one to sort of
prompt something so and that's just
that's that's really intriguing because
that's all point of view so we're
getting we're getting uh
everyone tells their own truth
and i'd rather ha i'd rather have that
in fiction and on the page and be able
to work it
than to uh try to understand
the real uh social media conflicts that
we get you know that's where i'm just
like
uh i i'm skeptical of all of them
is it healthy for writers to go to dark
places i used to think that it was
important to
liv um i
one of my favorite writers is william t
wollman and he's a guy that would go to
the would stay in the tenderloin and
stay at a um house to the you know and
do crack
and um
he and he's actively said these things
so i'm not hit but i even interviewed
him it's
um it's published but
he would actively go to these places and
and
i thought you know what i need to do
what he does not not to the crack end
but
i needed i want needed to be around
certain elements that were dark in order
to get inspiration and i've i realized
i don't i really don't um
it's uh
there there's dark everywhere i tell you
we don't need to seek it out there's
there's there's dark amongst us um
and
you know it's
and maybe that's why
vulman's written so many more great
books than i've ever written maybe maybe
maybe i'm doing it wrong and he's doing
it right when he goes
um
i mean he's he embeds himself in war and
does a lot of he's he's uh
what he does is gets there and feels it
and needs to know the whole story but
that's what he's writing i'm not writing
that and i don't need to
i don't need to essentially try to lose
my mind if i'm working on a character
that's trying to lose their mind that's
losing their mind and then
go wait a second i need therapy three
times a week now
uh it's just i think what i need to do
is to uh and what all writers need to do
is just go what's my personality who am
i i don't need to try to be someone else
i you know i would love to be a woman
but i'm not a vulman
so
it's uh
within my parameters
in my daily life
the dark doesn't the dark comes to us no
matter what i i don't it's
anyone who seems as privileged and you
know wealthy and think and it seems like
they have it all together no there's
dark there they don't need
to go move into a dark area
they they have a wealth of um
they have a wealth of material that they
can build from
from their own experience and
yeah sure so the sort of gonzo
journalism hunter s thompson
approach you don't have to necessarily
take that but
what about recounting dark stories
do you find sometimes with your students
that
they have a tough time or there's others
that they can't turn it off that it's
like flows like a a bad faucet well the
the problem with the true stories that
come in with my students is
they say oh no this really happened and
this is true and i'm like but it's not
interesting enough you're not you're not
putting enough conflict in there uh so
it's usually this happened and this made
me really upset and i'm like okay yeah
but make me care
so you can it could be based on
something true
but
to make that particular
event that was true to you and dark to
you
to to make it universal you're going to
have to really kind of dissect it you're
going to have to maneuver it around
you're going to have to
um
play with it and massage it to get the
essence of what happened we need the
emotional essence of what happened we
don't need the play-by-play so when it
comes to
true things that happen
i think a lot of the times when i'm
dealing with students is get out of the
play by play what's the what's the
what's the emotional effect that you're
trying to get through because that's
more there's more truth
to
um conveying the emotion than just
showing the play-by-play because we want
to get to the hearts of our uh
of our uh readers and audience
do you think that sometimes we think a
story is interesting and it's not
it's not really that
or that any any story can be interesting
even if it's just someone waiting in
line for coffee and there's
a person who's paying with two credit
cards and needing special attention
um yeah it's uh i think um
i think every story is interesting but
it has that's when the idea that's when
the idea
comes up this idea sounds good but it
has to be put on the page
the the idea that's not put on the page
is not a fleshed-out idea so
um
there yeah who wrote that book it was
the whole book is the timeline of the
book is a guy on an escalator
going down or up the escalator i think
it's called mezzanine and i can't
remember the author's name right now um
and that sounds like a very boring book
if you were to pitch that oh yeah this
whole book is based on a guy going down
an escalator in a mall um
that's like well that doesn't sound
interesting put it on the page though
craft it and it becomes something that
people are engaged with so i think we
can
knock out our
you know we i i find joy and fun in the
most mundane things and then i'll write
them down and then as i keep writing
them and massaging them then i'll be
like oh wait there is something in there
there's something in the mundane
oh that's cool but it ha i mean it has
to be written
for uh
for anything to happen that's so
you know if i were to write that story
about the guy at starbucks um
probably most the story would be based
on
what a terrible i what person i am but
from but not you know i that's how i
would approach it but i wouldn't
approach it from that point of view i
would approach it as the hero of the
story but it would be dissecting
everything that's terrible about my
thought process
while
as i'm writing the protagonist that's me
that protagonist is not going to know
that their thought process is terrible
and then that's where comedy will
probably come in because
the the
or you know the urge to do all these
certain things i'll look back at it and
i'll be like
that's when i find the empathy in other
people and i know and i realize the
stupidity of myself and the stupidity is
glorious and just like this this pretty
presumption this presumptuous
you know who am i to judge
and it's just like that's that's i think
that's the juice that's a lot of fun for
me